greetings folks I'm Kurt and today I am
joined with our designated Pokemon
expert Callie we have had a lot of
exciting news today because we had a
Pokemon Nintendo Direct
with a whole slew of things that are
coming so to begin
there's where do we begin there's a lot
to go over there's a lot I mean I guess
I would begin with um they have an
expansion pass yes so they're adding
more content to sword and shield
overtime and this is an interesting
topic I don't want to gauge because in
previous installments we've had the
ultra versions
yeah like the third version that comes
later which are if I'm correct full
retail games yes like back in my day you
would wait two years and then you would
buy the souped-up version of whatever
game it was but this one is different in
that you get to keep your save data and
then continue your adventure so I think
that's a really smart way to do it
rather than starting over fresh with us
I mean I've seen some like rumblings
about price but like you would be paying
a full retail cost for the ultra version
or the third version whatever they'd be
doing this is a thirty dollar expansion
pass for two new areas opposed to a full
$60 yeah you get to keep your safe so if
you caught all the pokemon you've still
caught all of the gallery pokedex
pokemon and you still have your shiny
charm and you still have an increased
chance to find shiny pokemon you'd have
to do all of that over again just to get
yourself to a place where you can do the
endgame content and I think that's
really smart the other thing about it
you can do the DLC from any point in
your adventure after you've reached the
wild area so you don't have to a finish
sword and shield to jump into these
things so it's not just that it's
in-game content so it is more
degenerative game but it's it's added
content and it's not all locked behind
the paywall too so I know everybody
complained about Pokemon being cut from
sword and shield but they're adding over
200 new Pokemon with the DLC with both
combined ones coming out in June that's
I love armored ones coming out in fall
which is
tundra and there's updates free updates
that are planned for the release of
those DLC what are those packs so this
is just an update that lets you have the
new pokemon the added pokemon in your
game the 200 yeah wait are we late when
are those coming so I'm glad you asked
so basically instead of like adding to
the gallery codec so you know how you
have like the National pokedex what in
your sorry the gallery pokedex the
region your pokedex you don't have the
national dex that was the problem but
you have the the regional tax so the 400
whatever that's one pokédex then isle of
armor the first expansion in june has
its own isle of armor poke vex and
that's about a hundred pokemon and then
crown tundra in autumn has its own
separate pokedex so you're trying to
complete those pokedex is on their own
so it's not like now if you didn't for
example if you didn't complete the
gallery pokedex if you didn't catch all
400 you aren't gonna have to catch more
to get the same shiny charm reward that
I got for catching the 400 so they're
separate pokedex is so the updates I
think I don't know exactly how it works
because they weren't clear but I am
would assume that the free updates that
are coming with the launch of each
expansion are going to give you those
pokedex is so you get the isle of armor
pokedex you don't get to go to the isle
of armor but you do get to trade with
people who have this you can have them
you can transfer them from Pokemon home
so you're still getting the expanded
pokedex for free so the the new pokemon
it's not like they cut pokemon to make
you pay for them later it confirmed
Venusaur and Blastoise with the gigantic
forums that obviously means you'd be
getting squirtle and Wartortle and
Sauron I'd be sorry and then I have here
the other ones because I wrote this
story on this this morning and these are
the ones that I spotted in the direct so
for aisle of armor you get like and rock
which means you get rock rough I love
him he's on my water bottle Kingdra
poker Rona and dead today
another little electric mouse like
Pokemon to join toga de Mario in Galler
Volcarona is also a very nice one to see
I love having better fire types
and then in Crown tundra you get a ton
of stuff actually they revealed so the
ones that revealed is like the regular
Pokemon that are being added included
aurorus knitter eNOS Elio and Garchomp
everybody's fav Cynthia's signature
Pokemon and then the Reggie's yours that
you're paying for the new areas you're
paying for the there's new gems correct
they are there there's a dojo which has
in Isle of armors like a dojo themed
okay thing
there's also read dents mm-hmm
tell me about those so the each area so
the areas are called Isle of armor and
Crown tundra they're kind of like wild
areas in themselves you can move the
camera freely you wander around freely
they show that off a little bit in the
direct the raid dense thing the thing
that's particularly two things you can
do some raids in the new areas that and
you can get Pokemon in those Ray's that
you couldn't get in the regular gallery
wild area I assume those are just the
Pokemon that are being added and then in
crown Tundra the second expansion you'll
also be able to explore the dens with
friends or with a party and so I'm not
exactly sure how that works they didn't
like give me any details so I'd be able
to post up with you and we could get me
in possibly and go in together and we
could go into the den so rather than
just battle the max raid Pokemon and
then like that's all you see of the den
you can actually go into it and explore
it and that's where you'll be able to
catch the legendary Pokemon so they're
adding like basically every legendary
Pokemon that doesn't include mythical
Pokemon so I didn't see like Celebi or
Jirachi
those are mythical Pokemon but all the
legendaries the legendary dogs
lugia hoo latias latias like tons I was
gonna write like I I was writing the
news story I was gonna list them all out
and then I was like nearly every
legendary Pokemon and that was it
because they just showed a screen of all
of them so they're adding those as part
of like you explore the done however
that may look and then
you have the chance to catch this legend
or your Pokemon there was something kind
of like that in omega ruby and alpha
sapphire they weren't super involved
caves but they were like mirage islands
that you could go to and then you had a
chance to catch a legendary there and of
course the one thing we haven't even
touched on yet we're getting new Pokemon
so among the 200-some that are being
added that we've talked a lot about what
do we know about these new ones that is
a good question Kurt so there's there's
a three that have been named so the
first two are in aisle of armor those
are cub foo and a Shi foo or Shifu has
two forms it could evolve into so one is
single strike style the other is rapid
strike style and they have different
types I think that's an interesting
Pokemon it looks pretty cool they have
their own gigant max forms as well of a
Shifu the two forms and then the second
Pokemon that they confirmed was calor X
which is a new legendary Pokemon that
has giant head and little Triforce it
sounds like a medicine with lots of side
effects sure does
yeah that commercial ECU like ask your
doctor before you take calor X it does
have a little try forces on it which I
know it's like they're obviously try
forces so I'm kind of like that's
interesting but it dudes got a big
conspiracies layout crown Tundra in
keeping with the adding a bunch of
legendaries there's two new Reggie forms
so you remember Reggie ice Reggie Steele
Reggie gee guests that I always struggle
to pronounce Reggie guess sure and those
are you could guess it was part of a big
quest in Hoenn to get the Reggie's there
adding two new Reggie forms that were
very interesting looking and I'm curious
to see what types they are and what
their names are because they're probably
gonna be really hard for me to say and
then there's what appears to be gallery'
inform z' of the legendary birds so
Articuno Zapdos and Moltres they made
them look really cool it is almost
certain legal Aryan forms that'll be the
first alternative form of a legendary oh
pretty cool sweet and they also revealed
gallery' and sloped
it has two evolutions based on there's
an item you can find on aisle of armor
that's slow bro I forget I'm gonna get
them mixed up again one gives you slow
bro there's an item on crown Tundra that
might gave you slow King I might have
that backwards but that's how you evolve
like I think like the biggest takeaway
is that it's a lot there's a lot and I
haven't even mentioned like a hundred
new clothing and accessory items new
hairstyle there's a new Marnie outfit
you can look like Marnie now that's that
it's cute it's cute cute cute so new I
mean the customization is already great
so having new customization is really
fun new like moves so move tutors on
each of the areas is this something idea
what that is is this something that
would have come with ultra the ultra
versions or the easy the new move tutors
um the new customization options maybe
those are the kinds of things that would
come in a third version it's an entirely
new area that's like a really good third
version okay you know that's that's like
your best hope we're getting to entirely
new areas there like the wild area but
like new like the isle of armor has a
bunch of different not climates what's
it called when you have different kinds
of variations no like beach and mountain
and both biomes there we go and they
they have like different biomes that
aren't seen in Galler so you're kind of
like getting out of what the UK limits
you to and I already thought that sword
and shield did a good job not being too
close to the UK like you have the area
that's kind of like there's that bazaar
and stuff but um
so we're I think it's a lot more than
you would get in an ultra version
especially like that size increase in
the Pokedex whatever you may say
whatever your opinion is on the number
of Pokemon that were included in sort
shield the fact that those are free is
really cool and you think
like that's that's just fullen that
gives you more stuff to do I I'm excited
okay so that is honestly it feels like a
fraction of what we know and what we can
talk about there is a bunch of other
stuff online that's much more detailed
GameSpot on a site that you may have
visited once or twice called
gamespot.com but there's a ton of stuff
there where we break down all the things
that we really really really know so
hopefully but for me as a as a pseudo
Pokemon boy I'm not an expert not like
you
I do like Pokemon I'm glad I got to
learn a thing or two from you wow I did
it anyways we're gonna have sie doch is
that confirmed No
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was great